the fifth declaration in the race to
succeed uh boris johnson straight to rob
powell at westminster and this rob is
the transport secretary grant shaps
perhaps somewhat of a surprise is it
it is but then at the same time actually
grant chaps out of everyone that has
declared so far and even a lot of the
people that may well declare in the
future is one of the more experienced
candidates in terms of time spent in
government time spent as a minister he's
of course transport secretary at the
moment but he also served extensively
under david cameron um as well um he has
said
in what appears to be comments that he's
made to the sunday times newspaper for
tomorrow
that he wants to stand to bring back a
more sort of traditional approach to
conservative government so he said his
immediate priorities would be to cut
personal um taxation now he doesn't
directly um have a dig at boris johnson
but he does make i think some pretty um
critical comments where he says that the
last couple of years have been tactical
government by a distracted center
and he says that the government now
needs to be more strategic
and not just chasing um the next
headline
i think the reason why people though and
you're right we'll find this a little
bit surprising is that maybe grant shapz
whilst has been quite a sort of loyal
ally to boris johnson someone that kept
the spreadsheets and did the numbers in
his 2019 leadership bid when there was
the vote of no confidence in boris
johnson three or four weeks ago
i think he said that he uh got the exact
tally right or was maybe one out when he
was calculating who was going to back
the prime minister and who was going to
vote against the prime minister so i
think maybe he's been someone that has
seen almost more as a kind of
kind of loyal sidekick if that doesn't
sound too derogatory towards him rather
than someone that in and of himself has
a sort of political power base or
personality in and of himself so i think
the big question for grant chaps over
the next two weeks is whether he can
garner enough parliamentary support
whether he can get enough of his fellow
mps to back him to put him in the top
spot grant chaps is also someone that
was frequently sent out during boris
johnson's premiership when bluntly the
pm was in a tight spot he was someone
that would appear in interviews to
defend the prime minister often uh
seemingly defending the indefensible all
of that said he is i think one of the
better communicators that boris johnson
put out there someone that um was pretty
skilled
at saying sometimes not a lot in
interviews
so
i think on paper a credible candidate
the difficulty is going to be though i
think whether he can generate that level
of support that is going to be needed to
take him forward in the rounds uh in the
in the out of the mps round and into the
round where conservative members um will
vote he has of course been in the
headlines and in the media quite a bit
recently as transport secretary with the
rail strikes he has adopted a noticeably
punchy tone towards the rmt and towards
um the rail unions but um yes another
entrant the fifth entrance to this race
i think there will probably be more
probably even before this weekend's out